Speaker 1: I have a really interesting
clip from the Joe Rogan program. Matt
Walsh has become an expert to the right
wing about gender and trans issues.
He did a documentary about trans
issues. He confronts people about
gender affirming care and all these different
things. And it turns out that he's just a liar.
He's just a liar. And there was a very interesting
moment wherein a yesterday on Joe Rogan's podcast,
Matt Walsh was saying millions of trans people
are on puberty blockers and hundreds of thousands
are getting hundreds of thousands of minors.
Prepubescent girls are getting gender reassignment
surgery and blah, blah, blah. It's all untrue.
Let's start with the clip. It's fact checked
by Joe Rogan's producer. Jamie, during the the
interview and everything. This is a clinic. This
is a clinic in critical thinking. Let's listen.
Speaker 3: How many people have had this done?
Depends on what I don't think
we have exact numbers, but.
Speaker 1: If we do have exact we do have numbers.
We have very good numbers on what's happening in
the United States. There are there are you can
there is data for how many procedures of just
about every kind are being done.
Speaker 3: Talking about
the drugs? I mean, millions.
Speaker 1: Okay. So millions on
puberty blockers. All right. Let's continue.
Speaker 3: Do you talking about hormone
blockers? Yeah, millions of kids have
been on hormone blockers. Really?
I'm sure someone going to fact check me on
that. But my my my guess is that we're in
we're into the millions now at this
point. Yeah, that would be my guess.
I can say for double mastectomy is the most.
Speaker 1: Okay, so. Millions on hormone
blockers might melt millions of miners on home
hormone blockers. The best data I was able to find
is that there's 120,000. Children. Struggling
with what is often called gender dysphoria.
Some small fraction of those at some point might
take some of these medications. He says millions
a year, the total number with gender dysphoria,
120,000. Only a fraction of those are taking
these medications. So firstly, do the numbers
really even matter to these people? I don't
think so. But there's the first like.
Speaker 3: I read a report recently
that there were over a.
Speaker 1: Thousand. Let me
back up because now they're on to something else.
Speaker 3: I can say four double mastectomy is the
most. I read a report recently that there
were over a thousand done between 2016
and 2019. And when you compare that to
how many were done between, you know,
28 and 2015, it's just a is a mass.
Speaker 1: Okay. But that's 300 a year.
Hmm. That that doesn't sound so high,
does it? But that's not even really right.
Speaker 3: Let's continue then, Chris. And
over a thousand girls and gender, gender,
gender affirming double mastectomies
in that in that timeframe when
you're talking about prepubescent minors.
Speaker 1: Oh, now, did you see what just
happened there? You're talking about prepubescent
double mastectomies for prepubescent girls. We'll
get back to that. That doesn't make sense either.
And he goes, That's right. Minor's prepubescent
and minor are two different things. I'm sure
you know that. But did you see how slickly
he slipped that in? I'll play it once more.
Speaker 3: And over a thousand girls had a gender
gender affirming double mastectomies in
that in that timeframe when you're talking
about prepubescent minors rape minors.
Speaker 1: So two different things. Now,
of course, you might say, do prepubescent girls
have breasts? Could can you even do a double
mastectomy on a prepubescent girl? What exactly
are you removing? And of course, if you research
this, it you start to find medical information
about it. It is very rare that prepubescent
girls actually have breasts. And you can read
about what happens to the nipple and. Okay,
you're right. I mean, we don't need to go into
detail about everything, but at at face value,
this doesn't make sense. Prepubescent girls
who almost never have breasts are having their
breasts removed. That's really weird. But then he
slips and. Right. These are minors. So you could
actually be talking about a 17 and a half year
old girl. Not prepubescent, legally, a minor.
Completely different situation. Doesn't make
anything right or wrong. But it's a completely
different situation than what he claims.
Speaker 3: And that's just up until 2019.
And then we know that there's been an exponential
increase with all this stuff year over year. So
it's it's a lot. It's too many. And no one having
this happened to one kid who says who. Tonight,
it's a lot more than one. Yeah. Look, if you're an
adult and you want to do that and you understand
who you are and what you are and this is how
you feel, you should progress. You're an adult.
This is a free country. You should be able to do
whatever you want. But when you're talking about
doing that to children, the fact that so many
people are on board and so many people are angry,
if you like, people are going to be angry
at us that we're having these conversations.
Speaker 1: No, but how could you be angry
that they're having the conversation?
The problem is that Walsh just lies.
Speaker 3: Yeah, they will. And I also.
I actually think that that that this
shouldn't this shouldn't be happening to.
Speaker 1: So now they've pulled up an article.
Speaker 3: That's a very small number,
if that's right. It says over the last
five years, there were at least 4780
adolescents who started puberty blockers.
Speaker 1: Okay. He said there are millions
of adolescents on puberty blockers. They
just found a study that says it's under 5000
over five years. That's under a thousand
a year, he said. Millions. Study says it's
under a thousand. Think about that.
Speaker 3: And at a prior gender
dysphoria diagnosis.
Speaker 1: Under a
thousand a year, he said millions.
Speaker 3: It's kind of undercounted. But that's
that would be a big 1000 people a year.
Yeah. Hmm. Yeah. I mean, I would guess,
you know, hundreds of thousands.
Speaker 1: Let me correct my wrong
guess of millions, because you found that the real
number is 900 and say it's probably hundreds of
thousands. I can't now get away with saying it's
millions because the data says it's 900. So let's
just go with hundreds of thousands because.
Speaker 3: But I could be wrong. You are
wrong. Million. Sounds great. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Right. It sounds. It's much
better for the story. So, listen, guys, there
are about 9000 dead. Everything I found from
medical journals reporting on this, there are
about 9000 trans surgeries performed annually
across the United States total. And that's
all ages, what's called the male to female
and female to male. That's any type.
Okay. That's mostly adults. Okay. And
what fraction of those are the situation that Matt
Walsh is talking about? I mean, almost none. Now,
then they all wait. The problem with these people
is then they will revert back to even one is too
many. That's different. The first case they make
is this is an epidemic. This is a fad. Everybody's
doing it. You just show up and they cut off
your breasts, even if you don't have any. If
you're an 11 year old girl, you've got no breasts.
They'll cut them off. What are they cutting off,
Matt? I don't know. They're doing it. Millions of
people and people, you know, all this stuff. Then
you give them the real numbers. They go, Well, one
is too many. But that's a different argument now.
Your first argument was it's too widely
available. It's absolutely horrifying and
good for Jamie for at least interjecting
and injecting some data into this.